Masters Tokyo was a movie The Incredible
Cinderella runs passionate fans and
insane plays made it a tournament to
remember but fnatic is now the only team
to win back-to-back trophies so the
question on everyone's mind is are we
witnessing the start of the fnatic
dynasty just not letting him get that
room they're not entertaining the
[Applause]
artists today
before you get into the video I want to
remind you that we just released an
episode covering all the hype from
Snapdragon mobile Masters thanks to our
friends over at Snapdragon Elite Gaming
for bringing us all the way to Japan to
experience this incredible tournament
where we witnessed one of the greatest
Underdog runs in brawlstar's history
make sure to check out the video in the
link below alright so although my sleep
schedule was completely these past two
weeks were a lot of fun if you're a fan
of valorent it's about time Riot held an
event in Japan because the atmosphere
was just incredible the group stage saw
a couple of notable upsets with EDG
eliminating Navi and T1 while Hong Kong
truly announced himself to the world
snake bite at his feet trying to get the
rest off there it is
detainment is it there it is hands up
six to claim the kill there's a rifle
here's the flash why not take a fight
together says I Dare You Second guesses
in with the off this man is playing gun
game score from to work here and once
again Prince and repeat run it on back
he's gonna find tire player he avoids
all the utility but he can't avoid
Batman yes he can it's away he's still
standing he's still doing damage fans in
the middle of CT he's trying to find
something further chichu's Gone Dead and
can't can
oh is he doing that EDG even managed to
knock out loud who had a very
disappointing tournament failing to win
even a single map this is not the loud
that everyone expected to turn up to the
event and you can call it copium but I
still don't like when teams Auto qualify
for playoffs we saw the same thing with
the guard in Reykjavik last year and
exit and Copenhagen so maybe it's just
an America's issue at this point but
personally I'd prefer if everyone just
had to earn their spot in playoffs by
performing in the group stage I know
some of you will probably say oh well
why can't these teams just not show up
to the event cold and yeah you're right
I just prefer if they just use seating
to determine the group stage matchups
instead anyways next I want to talk
about paper racks despite playing the
entire event without their star player
or something PRX pulled off a miracle
run with their content creator and
substitute cgrs filling in the stand-in
he knows he needs to rush this down he
needs to play For The Kill there's not
enough time to go for the plan he's
swinging around the corner hey man
some of the shorty doesn't find him now
I know Psalm is probably haunted by that
round but he had an otherwise amazing
tournament so I hope he's not beating
himself up too much and RG still
finished top four so I'm sure they'll
come back strong for Champions as for
PRX I just hope that something will be
able to compete with them at Champions
because once they're at full strength I
have no doubt that they'll be competing
for that trophy despite not having an
igl they're insane but next up we have
EG EG wouldn't have even made it to this
event had Hunter thieves not gotten
knifed by mibr's assistant coach on the
final day of the America's regular
season EG's Destiny was literally out of
their hands but once they were given
another chance they took it and ran with
it they qualified for Tokyo and managed
to get demon 1 a passport last minute
before going to Masters and pulling off
the craziest Cinderella run valorent has
ever seen they've got him trapped
there's nowhere for them to go
still playing such a dangerous position
it's two looking for
Lucio finds it
not able to convert on much more but
from the graves he brings Mr fallen down
with him jump spot spots one it's not a
comfortable plan
It's Gonna Get It Down for now closing
the Gap though you've got to respect
this manner
one is in the server mostly to get back
towards your back corner Ethan's gonna
trade out Leo it ain't over yet but
maybe Chronicle Maybe not maybe it's
Stephen one he's got the knives out a
2v2 out for a Chronicle to try and get
fnatic across the line oh my God
he saved them but it's Alpha up against
demon now oh my God
I still can't believe that last kill
demon 1 honestly might have the best jet
knives in the game right now but EG's
story this past year has been nothing
short of remarkable there was a time
where people were calling them the worst
team in the VCT and some were suggesting
that Potter should be fired but the past
three months have been truly special as
we've watched them develop into one of
the best teams in the entire world I
wanted them to go all the way because it
would have been an insane story and it
still is but fnatic is still fanatic
this team is basically the [__]
Avengers despite the 3-0 score line the
grand finals were relatively close but
fnatic proved why they're still the best
when it came down to the wire they
always stepped up to close out crucial
rounds
he
automate bustio if I don't get it
anytime soon this one's all but done
jungle gets away with it though gets
ahead of that flash it's darker on the
other side he's having a miraculous
round just not letting him get that room
they're not entertaining the idea
[Applause]
starts today fnatic are now the first
team in valorant history to win
back-to-back International titles and
Chronicle is officially my goat as he's
now the only player to win three major
trophies it was also great to see just
how respectful the crowd was towards all
the teams throughout the event and in
the end fnatic got the reception that
they deserved while hoisting the trophy
but this win has sparked a pretty big
discussion regarding where the roster
sits within the history of the esport
many people are suggesting that we're
now living in the fnatic dynasty or
fnatic era and I understand the
sentiment Ballarat has never seen
back-to-back winners on the
international stage so this is already
the most dominant roster the game has
ever seen but personally I'm still
hesitant to use those words balance
still doesn't have an astralis or an SKT
type team but if fnatic wins Champions
then I think it'll be pretty hard for me
to argue that tournament is a little
over a month away so we don't have to
wait too long to see if we're truly
living in the fnatic era
part of the reason I was cheering for EG
to win was that if eg1 Americas would
have two extra slots to go to Champions
through the lcq therefore Cloud9 would
have a better chance of qualifying so
I'm just like praying that Cloud9 can
get it together and like get that lost
spot and then go to Champions